mitten in der historischen altstadt rund
um das rathaus erstreckt er sich der
aachener weihnachtsmarkt
die meisten der überwiegend regionalen
händler verkaufen weihnachtsdeko und
geschenken
der kulinarische spezialitäten sucht
findet neben glühwein und punsch
deftiges und die süße aachener printe
das lebkuchen gebäck sprint man in
überlebensgröße ist der heimliche star
das macht das gewürz dritten man muss es
einfach mal probiert haben um zu testen
wie es ist die ganz normalen die kennt
man auch von zu hause vom geschäft
daraus aber die jetzt mit den gewürzen
ist schon was besonderes licht da
dunkelheit glühwein und was leckeres
so für mich weihnachtsmarkt der markt im
tageslicht im zentrum das markante
rathaus erbaut auf den resten der pfalz
von kaiser karl dem großen
südlich des rathauses liegen der
katschhof und der aachener dom
er steht auf der unesco welterbe liste
und ist das wahrzeichen der stadt im
norden erstreckt sich der markt mit rund
150 ständen
einer von ihnen gehört der bäckerei
nobis seit 1858 produziert sie original
aachener printen
die gibt es heute in vielen varianten
mit nüssen mandeln schoko glasuren und
sogar in einer karte große edition
das besondere an den aachener printen
ist dass sie im stadtgebiet von aachen
hergestellt gebacken worden sind oder
sein müssen und das hat was mit den
herkunftsbezeichnungen zu tun den
geografischen herkunftsbezeichnungen das
ist in deutschland auch geregelt und
deswegen auch geschützt im hinteren teil
der hütte zeigt während schröder in der
schaubäckerei die domspitzen entstehen
print mit marzipan füllung
das genaue rezept für den bonnern
printen teig ist ein streng gehütetes
geschäftsgeheimnis die grundzutaten sind
neben mehl und madrid mitteln viel
zucker gleich drei arten sirup für ihn
und katys dazu kommt ein mix aus den
gewürzen anis nelken koriander zimt und
peene und die mit jeder bäcker auf seine
art jetzt muss der teig noch in der
richtigen dicke ausgerollt werden ganz
normale kräuter könnte es sehr lange
haltbar weil da ist kein verderbliches
lebensmittel drin was heißt da ist weder
ein sahne milch butter nach maximal 14
minuten im ofen ist die basisrente
fertig und kann mitmischen garniert oder
schokolade überzogen werden
wie heißt das blinden trinken das ist
gut ich denke es sind nüsse darin zuerst
dachte ich es ist nur schokolade aber es
ist neben schokolade noch etwas anderes
drin gut sie haben eine ähnliche
süßigkeit wie diese in japan auch weich
und hart auch mit zimtgeschmack wir
mögen es nicht mein ding schmeckt mir zu
sehr nach weihnachten
man kann dem weihnachtstrubel aber auch
kurz entfliehen
mit einem abstecher in den aachener dom
die finden das einfach total süß und
schnuckelig hier diese heimelige
altstadt und es gefällt ihnen eben auch
dass man völlig auf ramsch verzichtet
und auf so krawallige weihnachts kirmes
und deshalb ist der aachener
weihnachtsmarkt auch so beliebt aber die
meisten touristen wollen beides die
geschichte der kaiserstadt und den
weihnachtsmarkt erleben